do you remember how you were when you
officially finally got
got got your name on the on the contract
with cam
i was 18 years old i remember because uh
we was on a tour bus and i was waiting
for the because we was on a tour for uh
diplomatic immunity too yeah and i
wanted to uh
um oh matter of fact cam wanted me cam
like yo i wanted the toy to be over
matter of fact
i'm like damn i want to get back and
pick up my check cause i had just signed
or whatever
and cam like nah b you ain't picking up
the check
until y'all drink a whole box of
scissors we celebrate
when he had the drink it was like 100
nips
i remember that i remember his drink
yeah there was just like dumb hot but i
ain't going to hold you i was happy
you know what i'm saying and i didn't
care i'm like i'mma drink at least half
a box and tell them i'm sick
but um yeah you know that was that was
that was dope you know i'm saying soon
as we got back
i signed i remember that was my last
time i took the train
and somebody took my ear off to death
like yeah what you doing on the train
don't worry it should be the last time
yo how i never
got the trices or how was it good yeah
now it was good
it was good i mean it's just different
it was this is just what was it because
i just remember seeing the ads and done
like like the source and [ __ ] like
i wasn't old enough to [ __ ] drink
obviously it was it had to flavor like a
uh
like a um not 90 knots like uh
hypnotic hypnotic purple yeah like a
purple hypnotic you know what i mean
type of chase i missed that whole wave
in life i've never even drank hypnotic
and i'd like to consider myself a mild
alcoholic now but that
but that's how you hear but then uh you
were drinking the credible hawks
but anyway oh okay okay okay
but look um missed that whole wave in
life that's how you know
the the the just the aura our aura how
crazy it was because
jim had that idea and
you know when the artist says yo i'ma
come out with my own liquor and all that
it doesn't matter where he at
is in his career it's dope it's
salutable but
we care about your music more than the
side
things that you're coming out with but
every when we came out with that
everyone ran with it that bottle was
like a rose bottle in the hood
everywhere we went it was just it was
just fire i mean just to
you know we was that influential i mean
when i toured the world that's when i
really realized how big dipset was
going to japan switzerland sweden you
know all those places i can only imagine
on my own at that